2017 is going to be the best year of my
life is what most people say until about
the third or fourth week of January then
they forget about the statement it's
gonna be the best year of my life
because here's what I can say about
myself in 2003 when it was going to 2004
I made a very simple decision I looked
around the industry I was in the
financial industry and there were people
smarter than me there were people that
had better market than me they had
people that knew more about the products
they mean there were people that were
better and skills than me but I made one
simple decision on what I'm gonna be
doing here was my test I was gonna
outwork I was gonna out improve and I
was gonna outlast my peers because
here's what I know for a fact when it
comes down to anything that there's a
competition or leaders bulletin on
here's what its gonna take place most
people will only work when people are
watching them most people will only read
a few books and then they'll stop
improving because they'll get to a
certain level that get some results and
they want to improve anymore and most
people cannot last a long time because
most people are going to get tired or
their belly gets full with the amount of
success they had and they plateau and
any time you plateau there's a fall
that's coming around the corner if you
truly want 2017 to be the best year the
beginning of the best years of your life
keep saying this to yourself I'm gonna
outwork I'm gonna out improve I'm gonna
outlast every one of my competitors say
it say it with me I'm gonna outwork I'm
gonna out improve I'm gonna outlast
every single one of my competitors in
2017 one December 31st 2017 comes you're
still standing up hungry going into 18
and guess what you're gonna say in 2018
again I'll work out improve outlast
everybody and if you can do this long
enough all of us in you look up and
you're one of the best in your industry
competing with everybody at the top of
the one-percenters
you